KATHERINE KUAN:
The reason why I'm
an Android developer is
because of the platform's
massive reach.
Building for Android means that
you can build something here
and it will reach people all
the way across the world.
In fact, the next billion
people coming online
will interact with the internet
for the very first time using
only a mobile device.
There's so many people who
are consumers of technology,
but I think it's so
much more powerful
to be a creator of technology.
Everyone has unique
experiences and strengths.
And they can draw
on that and use
that to identify problems
in their community
and then use technology
to solve that.
I really feel like there
is a big opportunity
to show people that
they can create
something really amazing.
You can imagine something
that you think should exist,
and you can actually
go and build it.
I can't think of anything
more powerful than that.
You can start your journey
to become an Android
developer today with Udacity
and Google's nanodegree.